so you grew up in LA yeah Koreatown my
whole life
whoa and so you grew up in LA and then
when did you start you know rapping and
doing all that stuff in high school yeah
but my old thing was like I always
wanted to be like an actor and comedian
like I was a child actor I was in a
Playstation one commercial you can you
still see it or no I've been looking if
I can't find oh yeah yeah it's hard to
find such I've been like really trying
to find it because that's just like a
funny thing to flex another what is flex
what does it mean explanatory video are
you flexing muscle you're showing it
right it don't give me a pen go give me
a pen give me a pen here so what these
are all I have these are all available
at Urban Dictionary wash washed fax fax
machine
that's a new one that's how I've been
saying a fax yeah fax machine yeah so
those are the four what you really
thought it was like facts like [ __ ] it
all comes out to say it's pronounced the
same way yeah all right so you're
flexing so yeah I mean I just I I you
know I was like into like I made my mom
like take me to auditions that I found
out about I was into it
Wow and then cuz I grew up as unlike TV
stuff cuz my parents were always working
I was like like latchkey kid you know
why right right it's all these home just
grew up on sitcoms and TV shows like
that and um but like early on want to
get attacked and when I got into high
school I was a stoner you know so I got
more music side right you know instead I
wasn't like trying to go outside [ __ ] I
was a stoner you know so I got into
hip-hop and I was into like rock bands
indie rock bands too so I look like some
kid who could be like a member of Weezer
the way I was dressed but I've wrapped
you know main so yeah and I wasn't
making songs or anything I was just
freestyling and battling because those
things like you don't have to like
record or anything
yeah just hop
this freestyle do whatever like you just
learned it in high school kind of when
you're younger around the environment
you're away yeah I'll go to house
parties you know kids be freestyling and
you know like it was just like a drunken
activity you know you'd smoke weed or
drink and you freestyle you impress like
you know kids around you and girls
around you and stuff so that's my main
reason that I started was just impress
girls and guess what every reason for
any wet [ __ ]
it isn't everybody always asked me like
you know because they want to answer
like 2,000 American story I'm like no
was to get [ __ ] yeah early on and it
may be later it could turn into
something else you know but it's like
kids got walk up to me and they go um I
just let you know that like you really
paved the way for me and this and that
I just wanted [ __ ] yeah I'm sorry I
wasn't that all the time they always
asked me those things I do a lot of like
college shows with Asian organizations
yeah and they're always asking the same
questions you know what I mean and they
want the same answers out of me but
whatever whatever your drive was you
still put pen to paper and you still
made it happen and put the hard work so
whatever your motivation was it's really
irrelevant right that is your craft is
your craft and you put the time and
effort in the funny thing is is like
early on though like when I was
freestyling and battling like that craft
was actually just me making fun of the
other person like deep about it it was
just like I'm just making fun of you and
your mom yeah shoes or whatever but you
is it one of those things where cuz I
know it instant and when it comes to
stand-up comedy people go oh that guy is
a great improviser or he's good with the
crowd work right but what I know about
the trick is he already knows what to
say 99% of the time because of just
through trial and error and what not
reprimanded a meditation so when you're
freestyle rapping how much of it it's
just out of your head at the moment and
how much of it is that well the format
kind of changed for battling before he
used to be freestyle like you go to an
event and there will be a sign-up sheet
and everybody signs up and they call
like randomly the next two people like
you don't know and then that that's when
it was like completely off the dome wow
that must be scary
yeah and you can come up with maybe you
could premeditate like a couple lines I
might work on anybody but if you know
that right you know right right right do
that if he's a specific right
nationality or race maybe you can have
some pre stocked right [ __ ] jab the
desert or whatever the format change
though where all of a sudden they
started doing these acapella battles
where there was no more beat you know
now those are to be because I think it
made it more like enjoyable to anybody
you know cuz before it was like you have
a beat and actually when you don't have
a beat you kind of have more time to
think - yeah and you prepare like
actually now like it's not really
freestyle anymore you actually come
prepared so it's like a boxing match
like Manny impact Pacquiao and
Mayweather fighting in a month
so these Conan's prepare for each other
teeth and that's not really that
freestyle freestyle but it is the
battling got better because I remember
like now when I watch my old freestyle
battles yeah they're not as good as I
remember it you know what I mean right
I'm like dude I was just talking about
that guy's shoes for like three days
yeah now but then when you watch the the
the like the written ones where they
prepare for each other they're like good
you know you could rewatch it you know
it's like a roast banner ah those like
roast battles that's a specific kind of
talent and I really do say it that mean
that I mean it these battlers are like
you know it is they're really into it
heavy like there's hundreds of leagues
across the world now and [ __ ] Wow Russia
Philippines like China like different
languages you know like I I know this
one Lebanese guy who's considered like
one of the top battlers and he's like
obsessed like I was doing a movie about
battle rap recently and there was a
scene where I was like attacking like
another person with Asian jokes like
Asian battle lines yeah I asked this guy
who I actually battled in the past I was
like yo do you have any lines that you'd
never used on me yeah he was like hot he
went to his rolodex where he had like a
section for fat people
he's Latinos he just had these lines
like all these lines is ready like for
whoever he's in a battle
next whoever Wow just a Rolodex of just
racial you know physical feature jokes
is there a line you can't cross no
people are mean no I'm there so there is
no longer racist like racial you know
there's really meaning a personal people
are pulling out police finally assaulted
example it's not say I was you know
doing it with you and let's say your dad
died from a disease for sure this person
facts come at somebody about their
mentally disabled mom oh that's
hilarious are like it's always funny
either it's just like ouch
yes you don't give a [ __ ] right you know
like that that wins you street
credibility okay not all the time just
people all have their different angles
like a guy who's like mean and doesn't
give a [ __ ] that's his angle my angles
more like the let's all make fun of this
guy together a kind of angle ah comedian
kind of guy and in that scene yeah but
there's a guy right in your face like
right there yelling at your face
spitting in your face like just Oh gross
just mean it really really mean I'm not
really the mean guy yeah like we're more
crafty then I'm more like wow so you
were the Pioneer then right for like
Asians would you say now Jin was like
the pioneer and I was like the new
generation after Jim I've never heard of
Jin you never heard of Jim Jane can I
just say that's a credit to you my
friend your lit your flex you're
watching you're up there fast yes you're
right
yeah you're all that okay we're gonna
we're gonna take a second for
[Music]